I don't people welcome to the report I'm
Dave Rubin I've got back troutman Jimmy
door
with me let's jump into nukes because
President Obama yesterday
said that his biggest worry is in russia
it's actually that a nuclear bomb
my co-op in New York City I moved from
New York that a year ago so I'm going
pretty good about this
but not only that but just a couple days
ago in the Netherlands a group of world
leaders got together to play some
nuclear war games to
its or to figure out the planning and
preparation and
fallout no pun intended if a nuclear
bomb was to go off
in a major metropolitan areas for each
world leader had a computer tablet with
touch screen options to make
100 4 responses to a series of poor
scenario films played out by actor so
they literally were watching actors
act out this the situation in the war
game a terrorist attack with anatomic
during bon takes place in the financial
heartburn
unnamed but Western metropolis this is
probably New York if it's in the case
the United States and in a competitive
environment with the ticking clock the
world leaders had to make rapid choices
before the results were presented to the
group
followed by discussion so that I think
this is really fascinating so they're
basically we're sorta playing like a
real time
half video game have acted out real
people
response being too something pretty
horrific
so I'll start with just the beef
level thing is this inevitable is a new
going off in 10 varsities
anywhere not just the united states is
it just ultimately inevitable that this
will happen let's hope not I mean I hope
the idea is that
diplomacy communication things like that
can prevent
a nuclear weapon a nuclear bomb from
going off in 10 varsity
the thing that I found really
fascinating about this was Chancellor
Merkel mmm
thinking that this was such a strange
being for these leaders to be doing and
I found that as a 1% and whole areas
because
women we sit around watching guys play
video games think black
it has no real-world application with it
going to
help you achieve we're do anything in
you got Tampa Merkel
in this situation it is man playing on a
tablet in this kind of war game scenario
thinking this isn't what we really need
to be focusing our time
energy and attention on is a war game
video game going to prevent this from
going off I would say no I don't think
that this is necessarily
gonna be the way that we're gonna
prevent it from happening but I I I
think
I would like to think that it's not
inevitable and that's a very rich
colored glasses way of looking at things
that
I don't want to live in that kind of
fear yeah week 11 that if you're
actually that's a pretty great visual I
picture now Angela Merkel as the mother
and all the rest of the guys downstairs
playing video games get outside
crazy kid I what is it inevitable that
this kind of thing I mean with the way
dirty bombs in that now it can be done
in a suitcase all that is it inevitable
no matter how much they prepare that one
day this kinda thing is going to happen
so I when I first heard
Brock say that I thought I can't believe
that has happened already
and then I thought about it a little bit
more and I really like that well
member they tried to have a couple
terrorists in an SUV
in Manhattan right and they could even
get the Bergen SUV bomb to blow up
right to this guy basically got a
firecracker as Carney can't get it to
work
so and then there was the guy with the
bomb on the plane he couldn't get it to
work in
so I'm like I think even if they do get
attorney bob they probably won't get to
work they will get we have looked out a
couple times right with yet with the
shoe guy in the underwear guy things
that don't
a really work out what do you make Obama
saying this though the way
shockingly that bizarre because he is so
measured
yet controlled so it's one thing if he
truly is in
that concern about russia I think that
okay we have to let diplomacy work
but the idea that he just suddenly out
of nowhere said well you know our most
important city it might be destroyed by
a new thing sorta
out of character for him as it like a
strange political may have it in my mind
it was him trying to take the focus off
job Russia of Putin of up what's going
on always
the criticism that he is getting for his
Foreign Relations has probably would
just like to let me say the craziest
thing possible that are scare the shit
outta everybody
was what I think that was my first
instinct reaction whenever I heard
him say that because suddenly if you
hear the president say that then your
fear
goes in a different direction yeah i
cant I thought about like wall
what are the people in New York thinking
when they hear that you don't be mad if
your kid in school
and the president on TV said a word
about someone blowing up New York where
the bomb what the f are you kidding me
should I be scared all the time
president saying in nineteen I thought
there was irresponsible him to say it
like that would scare the shit out of
people
living in there and help sell tickets
bring that whatever they call it a dirty
bomb
yeah it is and it makes me laugh a
little because you know my parents
always castigate me for swearing in my
comedy so much by gonna be so carried
away
at sounds like the bobbitt is coming all
the way it's going should check it if
you could get it back bar
I I everybody'll yet
yeah that you dirty Bob Baum look
obviously we're not privy to all the
stuff that's going on with these games
or what's really going on with who has
nukes and all that kind of stuff and
scientists that you know defect from
countries in latin
but do you think these games actually do
anything cuz they would do the three
years this isn't the first time they've
done this kind of thing
but it makes me think if a new course to
go off somewhere
it let's look at america percent what
they were talking parrot about that
a do you think the games would actually
matter did is gone
for olympic bench freedom fries you
still have every right to
I'll do you think the games would mean
anything cuz I feel like they would be
such
chaos in such a cascading effect the
blue to see that not a bit
things that they're doing with really
would really matter I couldn't agree
with you more
yesterday we try to plan for nuclear war
her
fields tire plug plan for when your head
blows up okay
let when what should I do after my head
blows up well first you put a a bandage
around
but no it so I think it's all you want
in a clear bomb goes up that's eight
games over
I don't you think I do get the team I
mean they have
I get the app they knew about their
religions but they they hijacked a plane
and blue-tinted buildings in New York
and we invaded Iraq and Afghanistan
what do you think someone blows of about
how well so we're gonna strike somebody
with a nuclear bomb
yeah I mean it that one goes up it
really seems like a domino to me
yeah well that is a good point because
it one way out of here we wouldn't
somebody with nobody
within a week we wouldn't somebody even
even with Obama who
obviously isn't as militantly say
although that some strange things with
drones will get later
as as but I it so is this just really
like
you know every science fiction movie
ever seen where humans are just gonna
destroy the year
ever gonna have to go the final easier
more on mars or something is that really
where we're all gonna this
I i think a lot of people would say yes
I think a lot of people would say that
humans have been destroying the Earth
since humans became humans I am
this is just a a quicker way going to
ensure that women
okay edgy step today
where you're at. what you think is this
in humans are we gonna just do it
ourselves between greenhouse gases
global
climate change in everything else yeah
well I wouldn't buy property in Florida
yeah I'm not I don't think we're gonna
make it past twenty fifty
I don't think we have to worry about
Social Security running out of money I
think we're not going to be dead before
I don't say miami is gonna be underwater
in like manner
you know people don't really yes the
crime say a one bike property in Florida
and
you know the whole thing people forget
like Syria what's happening
in what that destabilize the whole
region is a drought
that all started because of a drought
and people came into the city's protest
thing
and then the police overreacted it
started this whole thing soul you know
they talk about climate change having
political political impact it's
happening right now
rack it happened lorena something that's
what we should really yelling about
I'm focusing on because that much larger
problem and something that's really
happening every mission beat necessarily
thinking about
playing a game and wondering what would
happen if a nuclear bomb went off
we actually have something that like a
nuclear bomb that's going off
consistently that's causing huge
problems it just takes a longer period
of time
you think we have some progress around
here we started with the nuclear war we
brought around the climate change I
there you go all right let's talk
politics I thought this was pretty
interesting
at me silver who everybody loves this
guy right he predicted
at the last election he's a big numbers
guy who now is part yes can you do with
sporty got out the political world
basically
a do in sport but he did have some
interesting at
balked on 2014 at basically that the
republicans are gonna win back the
Senate which is this
scary scary thought we got much what
actually the
we think the republicans are now slight
favorites to win at least 6 feet and
capture the chamber
the democrats' position has deteriorated
somewhat since last summer with
President Obama's approval ratings down
to 42 or 43 percent
which is down from about 45 is that and
as compared to 2010 or 2012 the GOP is
done a better job of recruiting credible
candidate
with some exceptions okay to sober does
urge some caution there these are in
you know mind-blowing numbers that
Republicans are automatically going to
win but it is certainly interesting
and the what I sorta going into this is
that this
is and Obamacare thing that the
republicans have
order one messaging somehow
on that week here have socialized
medicine and not everyone has a right to
help you know that
arm do you think that's what this is
about the big somehow
scared enough people to think they have
to be voting for them
I'll definitely I think that people are
yeah all my God my health care change
that might make it can so people don't
know what
what's going on with the people even
know whats in their health care plan
till they get sick
so everybody's running scared
everybody's running free but Nate Silver
you know
it though I think a democrat way
over-reacted to this right because he's
not saying that's going to happen said
there's a slight chance that that might
happen at how much stock people put in
what he did because of what happened
last time with Romney but oh well
don't forget that he also need something
was wrong in 2012
not 2010 I think when he predicted that
the democrats would lose it again the
Senate and they ended up gaining seats
yes so he's not always correct yet so
well
that is a good point nobody's always
cracking of course these number guys
that are you know that's why he's
working for ESPN out a lot
easier dealing export numbers and
political numbers arm but what I was
thinking about this was that
the republicans as far as I can tell
have no particular message other than
everything's against
Obama so is anyone fired up for the
republican that's what i think is
interesting here people are saying we're
gonna vote for the republicans in 2014
but is anyone actually voting for them
where they just voting against about I
think a lot
that happens a lot with midterm
elections people to do tend to vote
against what the current status quo as
and the republicans do have a strong
message an you know attaching their
horse and carriage to
the Affordable Care Act they do have a
lot of messaging that they can use
and that was it wrong in predicting he
was at
he was bi was actually I think may be
dead on in predicting that 2014 we might
see
republicans take over the senate the
good thing they just as for the
democrats though and you already see
that happening they can take this
message exactly and they can use it to
raise funds and find these campaigns but
we do have
about 10 senate races that are really
important for the republicans really
important for the democrats we have
democrats you are
stepping down South Dakota is an example
you got
senator Johnson who is retiring and you
gotta
a really popular former governor running
in that state
a Mike rounds could could take over that
see that gives you a republican
North Carolina is going to be an
interesting race Kay Hagan one
that Senate seat from elizabeth dole
back in 2008 win at North Carolina with
a blue state for the first time
in my lifetime and it went back to read
in 2012 said okay Hagen is gonna have
atop a race on looks like time till with
its gonna be maybe one of the best
possible candidate pair speaker the
house there in north carolina
there are some people who are it's a
risk for a summit the democrats but
that's what happens in midterm elections
we've seen a history repeats itself
we've seen it
over and over again and I think Nate was
actually making kinda safe prediction
and suggesting that it might happen
interesting so do you think this is
sorta shows the strength of our
democracy in a weird way that in the mid
terms we do you often vote against
the incumbent President because it is a
little bit have checkup hours which we
seem to have
completely off I I wouldn't be normal
times I would say yes
abut I would say that the Republican
Party has gone so far off the rails that
now the Democrats or Republicans and so
we're not actually getting a
got so as far as a government that's
represented above the people's will we
certainly don't have that right now at
all
I don't think I mean look ninety percent
the people want to know restrictions on
gun legislation: happen
what does that mean that means that her
come in we look at the Banana Republic
you know it's like
were who with those their only serving
their donors when I serving us which
means that what we really need is a
different kind of campaign yeah
anything I come back I got it all the
time when it comes to politics yes okay
fine it's between
we talk everything we do here the
younger kids about money in politics and
who's bought and sold
why do we not even had any discussion
about
campaign financing where we used to have
that mccain-feingold thing what happened
that thing disappeared and now it
literally
is not in the news anywhere because the
people who are supposed to be talking
about it as the media right the fourth
the state right
and they're not talking about it because
the people who pay their salary in sign
their checks
wanna have influence in politics they
now work for these major compile
corporations for instance right so Brian
Williams and David Gregory they work for
General Electric a major defense
contractor they of course wanna have
influence on the government
so they're not going to go on their new
show and say hey we gotta get what we're
doing is horrible
we have to get rid a bit and by the way
the Iraq war is bullshit and we process
prop profit of it so they're not going
to do any that
and that's the problem the people the
criminals bought
the news media after they bought the
congress on others know watchdog anymore
that's why the only people talking about
is %uh
yeah well okay so that's making a fuss
are is the online news thing our
slightly up
we started here but is the online using
just wrap it all up to we the
the only a state that's left yet can
stop this thing I hope
I hope so because if you really look at
the way the world is working especially
the younger generation that's where
we're getting
our news we're looking to the people
online to inform us and and
talk to us and if we have an online
community and
getting more attention then alternately
don't they have to follow suit doesn't
mainstream media have to follow suit
its it's terrifying to think about now
because I'm that overt when
with Supreme Court overturned campaign
financing week retail the super PAC
it was in it was basically like money
laundering for campaign finance
and it's difficult to discuss it now
because you have to dig
in a different way did really deeply to
find out who is financing what and how
inhuman
I well said and I can promise you guys
that were not bought and sold
and don't trust Democrats don't trust
republicans
trust yourself ok II let's talk a little
bit about immigration we actually had
not done much about immigration on this
show
and I saw a Rasmussen survey
that was really interesting about what
americans think about immigration right
now so it look at the numbers
seventy percent of likely US voters
believe everyone should be required to
prove his or her citizenship before
being allowed to register to vote
29 percent believe laws that require
proof of citizenship before allowing
voter registration discriminate against
such boaters
and 61 percent say laws do not
discriminate
up three points from this time last year
okay so as I said we have not done a
tremendous amount on immigration so I'm
glad that we're talking about this
and this is why the thing that's always
an issue and we sometimes talk about it
a little bit more and then suddenly we
forget about it and it's hard to say
figure out which parties for what the 78
percent let's talk about that
that seems pretty legit to me that
basically eighty percent a country thing
you should at least
be able to prove your citizenship to
vote
does that c-myc sorta baseline
way to start well I think it seems like
we've been discussing it
so much in the media in a fear-based
way but when you really look at the
numbers for things like voter fraud
there so incredibly minuscule it really
isn't a huge
problem but we've kinda now made it this
whole
immigration issue in a fear-based issue
more than an actual
election issue but that the reality of
the matter is it
it does requiring this kinda voter ID
a it does and will continue to
discriminate against women against
people who are in lower income bracket
against the elderly and and the majority
in this is all political because the
people here that it affects
do tend to vote that so if you look at
this city it happen in red states
yet it happen in red states so I before
lawd what what's the rationale
this is what people say all the time
about white why is it that having ID's
would discriminate against women mine
are well
one of the reasons is because it cost
money to end up getting those ID's it
whether it's a birth certificate
that you have to use a few of them a
copy of a birth to get that cost money
you know fifteen dollars twenty backs
it cost money to get a driver's license
that cost money to get a passport
and it also requires transportation to
certain officers
in order to get some of these documents
and back and
be discriminatory against people who
don't have the fines to
do that I understand the idea have being
registered to vote I understand the idea
a making sure that voter fraud is it a
problem that really if you look at it
hasn't been a huge problem so okay so
I'm
I so I get all that for sure but I
basically agree with the
the people that they should at least
have to prove that you're legally
in this country to vote amaya crazy
conservative on this issue
ways well I mean you have to prove your
ID that you're 21 to buy beer so I don't
think saying that
just proving that you live in this
country might be true but not a
guarantee writing the Constitution
right so that's really the difference
there but I
I think that E if you once you are I
mean once I was informed about the
ramifications about voter ID law
I was against the voter ID law because
they know they can scientifically prove
that it's going to it's going to
eliminate a certain percentage of people
from voting
for all the reasons she just said right
because they're poor and they don't have
access
right right people like what I got an
ideal some people don't there's a nine
year old woman who's been boating roleid
and he doesn't have transportation and
she doesn't have money and she lives on
a fixed income
it doesn't have access to get to that
stuff but she can vote
and still sad but no you can't but now
because we're not gonna you can't do the
state's certain things that we're gonna
change
so there is about again this is a
solution in search of a problem
there is no border up there is no border
a fraud nobody's going boating twice
it's not happening sold
the only reason you would wanna
implement this
is to do is to make sure you tilt the
favor and talk and play with the
republicans
and you discriminate against some other
democrat votes that the only reason you
would do that and to that point it does
seem that the republicans are the ones
that one
or this all to happen all these voter ID
think so they're not doing it because
the country they're doing at the moment
and putting it right you don't hear that
Arizona North Carolina yes
yes I just like to get from pennsylvania
we've seen that clip a budget time to
the guy said
a voter ID which is going to guarantee
the state a Pennsylvania for Mitt Romney
done you using that clip that's why they
do it then pick endured again the news
media
pretending it's a legitimate argument or
not or exactly what they're doing isn't
voter suppression
that why isn't a reporter screaming from
the top of their lungs about voter
suppression in america
it's because the bottom paid for and
they don't want to piss off half the
people who want to suppress the vote
right so what would you guys say to Bill
O'Reilly who is on TV every night saying
that
if they if you let these immigrant that
already in the country
the people that are here illegally but
they are acting as you think if you let
them in they were although democratic it
will be the end
love the Republican Party which may in a
weird way be bad for a political system
if we really only became a one political
thing even though we're pretty much a
one political thing as a
but what would you say to that argument
I would say that is that's just fear
mongering that's just trying to scare
people into believing that there's a
problem that nearly just
isn't a problem you know if they're
they're making a discussion about
something that
isn't ok a huge issue there are so many
other things that we should be focusing
on talking about
and this is a way to try to maintain
control
and in these very red state yeah and
also ninety-five percent of the people
that
are here even if they're here illegally
are perfectly legal
people within our borders you mean
they're working jobs and have families
II know people personally who had family
split up in people been deported that
can see their children for twenty years
I mean all kinds what is known bill
o'reilly says well we can't let all
these immigrants coming casting a vote
democratic and the republican party what
that really means is
hey there's a buncha people are we're
gonna have to appeal to with our
policies now that we don't want to have
to a penalty with our policies
so we can just to keep them away from
voting we can just keep on appealing to
a narrower and narrower Bay some people
that's exactly what they think oh my god
we're going to have to address the
reality that
what we want america is what most people
want america
holy shit rest then you should have to
change your problem you party Sat
platform
or you go away right anything is in
america we're all children or
grandchildren great-grandchildren
%uh in every hundred give us your tired
your poor your message somehow we don't
want anymore
unpack so file for this club to talk
about immigration protest but
what do you think about securing the
border because that does seem like a
legitimate argument to me at least
that for some how we should be able to
secure the border and then
you know to stop new immigrants from
coming in illegally while we deal with
the issue not that we ever do anything
in the correct order but at least I get
that argument at least
make some sense to me I well
you having a 10 the it's a it's it's
definitely an important issue to think
about we have
all that the legislation really in place
to deal
with illegal immigration we just don't
have a lot of real enforcement
com we are we are backwards we all we do
you do things kind in the
in the wrong way we do approach things
and
in a cart before the horse kinda way
when it comes to you a immigrations when
it comes to things like emigre could be
the last five years we could have been
dealing with border issues just deal
with
figuring out how do we secure the border
and then say okay we've dealt with that
now we can deal with the people who are
here and the people who want to get him
but we never deal with anything in the
correct order do what no of course that
will
its it's because this is crazy you know
dual input a
interest rates for corporations big
farming corporations I'm a gag
where business they want I it a cheap
labor
but then they don't want them to be able
the boat so they can vote into a union
right so they it's it's that put they
want to hear to work with no-one treated
like human beings right
with the legislation like there are
people who are here and people are
willingly paying them under the table
and paying them tax free
and those laws are being enforced
because there are so many big
corporations who are benefiting
from that kind of thing so that it's
already there we've established what the
legal but
it we are necessarily enforcing it
because there's a benefit
that is the you're a Jimmy about the the
irony of the republicans because
especially the mexicans that come in
they work at jobs that Americans don't
seem to work in the bust
their asses per 18 hours a day during
the hardest
labor-intensive jobs and then they don't
get much for return and that's good for
the corporations and really
we know the leasing mexicans coming in
here taking our jobs taking our jobs
they want this gate but I'm
I'm keeping it people okay II I really
love this story so
the government has basically been
actively
trying to destroy 3 great companies and
yeah
it comes down to money at Tesla number
air BnB so
they're all doing interesting innovative
new
the business models that are changing
the way people
communicate and commerce I so let's look
at the major
info about 3 a.m. and then out paying
for it
to you know about Tesla they built in
electric are the people actually want to
buy
there's a lot of them here in LA they
boldly sell directly to their wealthy
customers rather than subjecting them to
auto dealerships which helped
keep the cost down to get through the
middle man and because auto dealers
account for as much as 20 percent of the
state sales tax legislators work against
them
that was happening in New Jersey as he
would go New Jersey legislator added
more burdens to rules already banning
direct sales of cars to customers
now test was effectively can't be sold
in New Jersey
so this is an electric car that we talk
about all the time
and what are we doing we're regulating
it into oblivion let's look at an
excellent
over which we have here and I use last
night
after din car service that connects
drivers and riders a minute
it presents a threat to traditional
packed leaving right services obviously
rather than fight for customers by
cutting fares are increasing the number
cab
taxi commissioners and city councils are
instead trying to regulate my brow to
business on the ground that a bright
unfair
and unfair competition yeah because the
tactic guys had a monopoly
and now they're not happy that because
of our apt we can figure out a way to do
this
cheaper and a more pleasantly actually
and then finally air BnB which is
website that allows people to rent out
apartments and homes therefore
despised by conventional hotels and
thirties who rely on travelers
and at worst acted Austin charges host
and annual licensing fee and limit the
number of participants
Portland has banned in residential
neighborhood rate control advocate in
your career teeming with
up with the hospitality industry fish
try to shut it down
okay so basically what you have here are
sort of three crowd
source that in a way crowd funded
businesses better
making better products that people want
and what's happening of course the
government is jumping in and trying to
tax them away
their B&B one is the easiest example I
think because the the hotel
lobby is powerful and they don't want
people being able to rent their rooms
easily
you you own your room a pretty sure even
if you're renting your like to rate your
room out usually
I am what to do in a situation like this
could be easier to do you guys use these
three
any combination of the three things yeah
I have used humor used air BnB
am ever is actually really a it it's a
great app it an easy way to get from
point A to point B and one other things
especially if you're a woman
is you can read these reviews %uh
drivers and you feel a little bit safer
and another great thing is that drivers
can then review passengers to
yeah driver knows not to pick up
so-and-so because he was there around a
pasture
a passenger she was around a passenger
that doesn't mean
government has done it throughout
history and this is such a complex issue
me thinking about tackle this isn't the
first time that we tried to kill and I
like her
but here it is happening again and this
is all gonna tie into the things that
we've been talking about
I think about media being all about his
major corporations think about Tesla you
had a couple a test was that caught on
fire for different reasons
and it became is huge news story that
they're suddenly on saving the number a
test was that actually caught on fire
minutes we'll compare to other cars and
all that kind of stuff is interconnected
all this kinda stop is all about
taxpayer dollars it's all about lobbyist
it's all about the money that's going
into families campaigns its all the
stuff that we have actually been talking
about
and it is complicated it's not just
about these aP's
this stretch is pretty far the actor
Jimmy I hate to beat our our money in
politics thing again but this
is this is like a very personal example
I think it's different then
the political example if our politicians
being baht baht of the
for some foreign policy interests or
something I get this one
over should be allowed to exist should
it not well
I was always taught that the definition
of fascism was when
that government and corporations
colluded to screw the workers
right is that that's pretty much right
so that's what's happening we're
close that's what this is right so we've
come up with something that helps the
consumer and the government steps in and
says now that
at hurts the business so where neck
we're gonna protect the business
and not the concern that the citizen
which is the same thing that happen
when senior citizens were going to
Canada get cheaper prescription drugs
because Canada does a very same thing in
negotiated up
depression drug prices with that
pharmaceutical companies which the
United States not do
so they would go there to get them
cheaper the government then stepped in
because the pharmaceutical said they
were losing money
but these people buying a cheaper in
Kennesaw the government didn't do that
and that is the definition
a batch is a and by the way we should
note that it's not that they're
colluding just with business it's a
certain type of business because
these are businesses that pay taxes but
they're not the ones that are on the end
with the politician right so it actually
it more nefarious even then just saying
it acted because it's not just a
business could
these are businesses to the government
could be in business with them but
they're in business with their own guys
an act even more
per person away you know i mean we've
sort evolved and have these great
three Greek things and electric freakin
car we've all been waiting for
and the government is still figuring out
a way to have a week watch this thing
yet what I mean in in think about it
happened it happened it throughout
history politics
and doesn't stay in touch with exactly
what the people are
are moving forward with and this is
another your prime example a bit and
hopefully now because we are
interconnected were using
app that we all will as at fittest and
I'm gonna try to be positive here
because I don't want to come I don't
want to be
you're depressed throughout my entire
life Friday but
hopefully we can and what we should do
is is speak out as voters and speak out
as can as
as consumers I mean Adam Smith said it
is the free hand the free market we all
are moving in that direction don't cab
drivers don't
don't hotels don't other people have to
step up their game shouldn't they have
to step up their game
and I would love to think it's so that I
can sleep at night and wake up and you
know not want to
cry and stay in bed I would like to
think that we do and that we can try to
have some level
love up control over it at consumers
because these
these businesses are going to continue
making money and government politics
as usual they have to catch up and then
they are always
twenty years behind so to that point is
is the saving grace is this
do we need freakin Facebook to come in
by Wilbur because Facebook could
potentially
fight the government a little bit you
know you mean they have the money and
the lawyers may be like it is somehow
these giant corporations are they gonna
be the ones that the by the cool things
to push out the middle guy well I mean
that certainly sounds like one solution
to that sounds like a horrible collusion
article I felt right book growth yeah
it's just like how will we need that
many Deb
we need a benevolent corporation
fighting against the nefarious
government that doesn't seem right
rammed by the way Facebook national
benevolent not happen rights so
they all seem to be their hands are all
dirty and a
yapping or get me another Teddy
Roosevelt you know we need a guy to come
in and bust up the trust to get the
government back to the people
perfect ending for that when I think I I
let's talk about drones you know what
everyone when you picture drone when you
see these things on the news all the
time it's always a drone
somewhere in the middle east usually of
course in yeah man or something
firing in and usually killing innocent
people in double tapping like that that
we talk about all the time here
but you know we are getting drones here
they're going to be delivering our
packages
and they're also be stealing your wifi
and figuring out what's on your phone
at yeah let's let's take a look at the
video Avenue drawn it's coming out
that the hacker using technology
installed on a drone
to grad cell phone information from
people below this technology has been
used on cell phones and laptop
one day it could be installed in a
larger aircraft think helicopters are
small plane
down the road and I i see what the
device is a must for the people walking
down the road
you can also see your username passwords
do credit card information
and get dead in some cases your home
address
yeah so that's why we talk about drones
all the time because we're doing it over
there but too loosely quote george bush
it's going to end up coming over here I
mean look
even if they're not gonna be shooting us
which ran post talk about you know you
walk out a
at a 7-eleven they're gonna drone strike
is so even if it's not that level
this is pretty scary stuff because we
know that they're taking our information
already in the metadata and all that
but now that we're gonna have drones
flying around they're gonna have access
to all the stuff
what is the same thing that's been
happening many people have been creating
these your fate wifi hotspot and
stealing people's information
the difference now is that its mobile
and these little quad copters that are
being used in photography and used in
videography
there inexpensive and its easy it's now
on mobile:
and that makes it more terrifying but
this technology
had existed at 10 the prices sadly that
we have to pay for the convenience
abusing our founds to bank using our
pounds per email using laptop something
like that
we its a it it becomes our
responsibility to be aware that these
things
do happen and we have to be really
careful with how we approach wifi with
our cell phone devices
it it existed this has happened before
it's just now like I said it moves
around and it can
it can get more information more quickly
but if you think about it
i working at a business that's all about
online videos and that's what I talk
about all day long I find the people
behind them
it's not hard actually to find all this
information
I can do it in 10 minutes just with
Google searches and looking for Facebook
and looking for the things that people
post in Twitter feeds on Instagram feed
you think about the nine-minute you'll
be able to save when you have your own
paths that pic jimmy cooney appear more
do you fear just the hacker
the guy that's gonna do this or do you
fear the government doing this with
which you think is actually worse
you know i mean i i cause I worry about
both of them but to
I guess I'm more worried about the
government that seems to kill because
they would be shielded from prosecution
things like that they can
yeah I would be barfing mean this is
them
I don't you know they say privacy I
don't know I mean all what are we
supposed to do today it's I just assume
that they know everything about me at
all time it doesn't matter what browser
are used to surf the web or have their
gonna get it
if they want it and it just seems like
somehow we've
it's what we're through the looking
glass right it just seems over now
and your idea privacy is done right you
want business life
being connected we we like all the way
the world has are a lot of people do
they like that everybody's connected
but that's the other side a bit that's
the the price we pay me because we're
living our lives
on nightline although that is acceptable
and not just by drones like that's the
thing people are really scared because
the name drone has this
you know it it instills fear in people's
hearts
but it's already you happening it's been
happening for every time
at No I N was never a waiter or you know
what restaurant but
I always thought about that when you use
a credit card to pay and they too do the
club thing and they would have all your
information
right there any person who's a waiter or
waitress
had urine for your credit card
information on them and yet we never
worried about that and they could have
stolen it used at any time they won it
so that a little bit have something to
be said about this that maybe
our information has been out there all
along and not say oh cuz I know a friend
who wouldn't you want to buy a plane
ticket using the internet the the prey
to put credit card in the internet like
so when you call them up but just
couldn't their computer
you telling telling at the USAF so I
yeah I mean I guess you know we've I
guess he just cross your fingers and
just be glad that nothing has happened
so far
her right now D increases we just have
to be more
aware we just have to continue to stay
aware of how to protect ourselves in and
businesses also have to step up to the
plate and protect with their
you know n and credit card companies do
that now they say that you're not
responsible for fraudulent charges the
problem though is that we as consumers
end up paying a platter that
look at the bottom line is affected by
how much money they leased to fraud all
the time
we have to be informed consumers we have
to be able to protect their own
information but we also have to be aware
and keep ourselves safe because their I
more
our information is accessible than we
think and we're the ones putting it out
there
are you saying you know read the 50-page
thing when you signed up right to
I don't have a you're on a team of
lawyers with you sitting there going to
well bath
I don't know if you can like this I miss
because correct you because this is
there about right
no money and no one has the time to do
that because we connect everything
through our we live our lives online
yeah fine a point on it I think the
through the looking glass i think is the
perfect way for this are we had a really
interesting time right now
where for a while we had all this stuff
with a for the first 10 years a
mobile phones and the Internet we all
had it we all update everyone found porn
everyone is excited
now worry in the through the looking
glass part which I don't how long it's
going to last like you agree like a
three year thing here
I've ever gone yet we had all this stuff
we love it but we also hate it
and now what's the what the other side
you know in a May giving Assad I'm
getting a little esoteric where
pickle their is I think that it's
actually
going to continue to to increase their
their
a a great but they cannot call the
circle David Akers and it that this
book it's written about the concept of
total transparency
total transparency the idea is that the
company he created in this book
represents our company kind of like
Google and as people
you're always going to have the people
who say I don't want any more technology
I don't want anymore to happen
but the way that the world moves you end
up
almost being forced into it bad in the
book
total transparency means all people in
government costly having cameras on them
all people everywhere costly having
cameras and broadcasting that to
everyone
and the weird thing about it is that as
you read something like that
you can see that something like that
could easily
happen because as we move forward with
how this technology
we get more accustomed to it we get used
to it doesn't feel a scary it doesn't
feel as intimidating and we keep moving
forward
with that will will we stop will it stop
II didn't think we needed more
technology in like nineteen ninety-two
you
you know and then suddenly here we have
this world I have a phone that has more
technology in it than that
apollo that went to the moon so you know
we keep we we we don't stop it we'd keep
buying into it we keep moving with that
because we had this whole concept that
it's better to be
connected it's better to to put our
lives out there
you can become narcissistic and away
can't stop progress bring it on me
well you know what they say I the
definite 7 narcissus is that someone
who's better looking than you
yeah and murdered art will this lead us
to a perfect segue for our final segment
here
because there are a buncha maps that are
popping up there are
purely to give us online anonymity if
that actually
exists I we've got a lift the cup love
them
there's Khan fight which erases your
text messages right after their red
there's whisper which share secrets
anonymously
and there's yet the attack anonymous
social chat room
I so this is perfect considering the
topic we were just talking about
so going to your point above the circle
which if you guys are watching
guaranteeing a quick break before this
will add if a tree get right back over
there
I about everyone being completely
transparent with everything
is the is the anonymity thing the next
thing before that you know in first we
have to
first it we put all the stuff out there
which were all doing now next it'll be
we'll all do it anonymously
and there's plenty people do when
they're ready and then after that we get
to the place
have total everything out it doesn't
surprise me that this is a trend right
now but didn't we start with the
internet kind of having their
did it we did isn't that how people
started in the chat rooms that it was an
honest and people were talking to each
other under
there are some big screen name in now
because I things like Facebook and
Instagram and you have a profile picture
it became a little
more public it's strange to me
because we become this this culture up
sharing and we have become narcissistic
and weigh like we want everyone to know
our ideas and our thoughts
its traders wanting shop equipment yeah
I don't post it that everyone knows
where they are going on but
exactly but it's a it's strange to me
that
people feel the need to share their
deepest darkest secrets
with their friends without their friends
knowing exactly
who they are I mean what happened to
conversations no in the end the argument
is well if somebody is having an issue
with substance abuse or if someone is
having
I real personal problem what happened to
actual personal contact where you can
find somebody and say I need your help
and instead of putting it out there for
all of your friends to judge and then
sit and discuss I know this anonymous
but your friend you know they're gonna
get together to do you think that that
was Bobby
do you think that I think he would be
the person who said that this is like
gossip on a weird new level I don't
think it will
I hope it doesn't their last because it
seems like its opening and
a door to more negativity then
positivity so but could there be
something cathartic
about this online anonymity thing I mean
if you are a nap if you were just having
a crazy day and frustrated by something
and you didn't wanna tweeted
with your name attached to it you know
something really angry
that you could just click on one of
these things get it out there and feel a
little better and move on
would would you like that the thing with
the whole online it's just that
everybody being online everybody's
opinion matters just as much as
everybody else's opinion
and it requires increasing levels of
cruelty just to keep up
go to any video on YouTube check out the
fourth commenters comment a always rips
the third commenter
for the forthcoming there's always a
jerk and the fifth guy the newcomer try
to find common ground among everyone
and for that every week for that the six
commenter impugn his sexuality
so at you know they also say that the
problem with anonymity on mine is that
it could Ikeda
creates police right you could bully but
let's remember who the biggest victims a
bullying
it's the police right there ostracized
are stigmatized and that their creed 3
like monsters in society
into all the boys out there I just want
to say it gets better
yeah do we need
anonymity now more than ever because a
ball the NSA's
look I don't even believe that any the
zaps truly work because I'm pretty sure
that the government wants to get in
there and figure out the they can
somehow track it
to your IP address on your computer or
something related to your phone
but let's pretend per second that these
things truly are not a myth
there any air at that point then it has
some work right because we need to be
able to share secrets with everything on
our the NSA
but when you share secrets on line this
is what to wear rearranged to me yeah if
you're thinking about putting your
information out there on line you need
to assume that at some point somebody is
gonna figure out exactly who it is
if you want to maintain anonymity if you
want to keep your ideas anonymous
why she what about their online in just
under some shield you know so little
about somebody for example that working
for the NSA now let's say that there's
things that Snowden has been revealed
that they know re: are even worse
something like this would be a
legitimate wave getting it out there
well and you Bay you think that with our
technology if they will let my point I
don't believe that I would work because
I follow the trail the IP address to
write and and figure out exactly who
that was like maybe I wouldn't be able
to figure out just sitting on my
computer reading this anonymous quote
but if somebody wants to figure out who
who made this post I mean Google keeps
everything that you ever search for a
minute if you really wanna for grabs
yeah it would be possible to get that
kind of information and again that's the
risk that we
run in living this tech not living in
this world where everything is
Ste it's accessible we if the weird
price that we pay for the convenience
that we strangely
want and for the at my opinion matters
feeling that we
all seem to strangely wanna nothing that
we all do but that
as a society got public people talking
about our feelings of pride
not us no we're fine I yeah I mean do
you think that there somewhere
to in it in a day in age in the NSA and
buying all that you think they're
if if they couldn't track this stuff to
do some work to do it I think they're
I mean you know many times I wished I
was anonymous online to be able to say
certain things I
you know instead of having every sign in
T Google
hey under a fake name and then go to
that commenter on YouTube in reply a new
asshole
can use right your fake name here so i
cant my baby where you've been writing
about me i
they name is GM door Gier
without no during store hours yes but
every time I have you on the show
there's this guy gym do it was like that
Jimmy Durden
bagi he goes nuts boy fantastic and on
that note
I want to thank my not anonymous get bet
ravin Jimmy door their twitters are
right
down below subscribe like all that good
stuff we're not tracking you the
government is but don't worry about that
and that we will do it again next week
like that